you and your buddy uh Robert De Niro we
always think of you guys together as
buddies like you hang out all the time
it gets to the point where you know we
didn't see each other for a few months
but when we see each other it's yeah
right do you do an impression of him
well I don't really do impressions of
Bob but there's one that I really like
and it's from Goodfellas that I it's
become part of my uh Mantra in a sense
it's a scene where where Frank Vincent
playing Billy Batts really really gets
under Joe Pesci's skin I'll go home and
get your [__] shine box they have to
pull Joe away from him screaming kicking
and uh Frank says what the hell is the
matter with him you know what what's the
big deal can he take a joke and so Bob
is about to have a drink and he goes
well you you did insult him a little bit
and then Frank Hansen's Frank says no I
didn't and then Bob does the best he
goes okay okay salute and we know we
know what that okay is yeah
I always I always do that you didn't
insult him a little bit and okay okay
okay let it go okay